Steve Bannon ist von seinem Posten beim rechten
Nachrichtenportal Breitbart News zurückgetreten.
Der frühere Chefstratege von US-Präsident
Donald Trump war Vorstandsvorsitzender bei Breitbart.
Im Zusammenhang mit einem neuen Buch des US-Journalisten Michael Wolff
hatten sich Bannon und Trump öffentlich überworfen.
Der Präsident erklärte, sein Berater habe
im vergangenen Jahr nicht nur seinen Job
im Weißen Haus, sondern auch seinen "Verstand verloren".
Hintergrund ist ein Treffen von Trump Sohn Donald Jr. mit einer russischen Anwältin
im Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2016.
Bannon hatte kritisiert, dieses Treffen sei
unpatriotisch gewesen und sprach von "Hochverrat".
Seine Kritik wurde in dem neuen Buch veröffentlicht,
inzwischen ruderte Bannon zurück.
Bannon, ein Bindeglied zwischen den Erzkonservativen und Trump
hatte bis August 2017 im Weißen Haus gearbeitet.
Im Zuge eines Machtkampfes verlor er seinen Posten.